comme papa maman panne à montanes femmes
oh ça alors bonjour ici aussi c'est
incroyable vous vous rendez compte
j'envoie parmi vous qui sont grands
d'autres qui sont petits et puis il y en
a qui ont des cheveux longs d'autres des
cheveux courts et c'est comme ça depuis
ce matin dans l'est aux enfants dès que
je vois quelque chose immédiatement
après je vois le contraire tenez ce
matin par exemple je me suis préparé un
grand bol de gloubiboulga mon bol était
plein joliment j'ai aussitôt après le
bol est évident prends toi oui bonjour
casimir nous et n'ont vu sinon c'est
vraiment pas le moment je t'assure j'ai
des ennuis avec mon ballon la tige
métallique était fausse et puis
impossible d'arriver là fixé dessus
excuse-moi 6 cohérent non enfin c'est
pas grave grave mais à toutes leurs
questions à l'heure aux pages oubliées
bonjour salut qu'à venir tu vas bien oui
oui avec moi qu'il a beaucoup d'ennuis
des ennuis quelle drôle d'idée il fait
beau mon casque et bien rangé ça ne
pourrait aller mieux
tu es sûr absolument hors norme et c'est
effrayant pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des
tuyaux des aînés eh bien tu as des
ennuis juline en apport bien rien
d'effrayant à ça mais vous ne comprenez
pas c'est comme ça de plus ce matin des
droits quelques shows et immédiatement
après je vois contraire c'est terrible
arménie et renier prénom c'est comme ça
tous les jours
mais oui simplement d'habitude tu n'y
fait même pas attention pour qui
marchent chaque pas est le contraire de
celui d'avant
ah bon 4 tu es tu expliques tu es mais à
pieds devant
malakoff alors tu as le pied droit
devant mais le pied gauche derrière
avant de l'appareil avec ça tu as
maintenant le pied gauche de van et le
pied droit derrière c'est le contraire
et ben voilà casimir tiens je vais même
te prouver que les contraires norian
terrifiant c'est comment non non en
faisant jouer à wii j'en ai les enfants
sont d'accord les enfants venez avec moi
on va faire un jeu comme eric loi
mettez-vous en deux équipes une équipe à
droite de julie par ici est une équipe à
la gauche
tout le monde est bien installée et bien
au niveau d'antan nous allons jouer
ensemble au jeu des contraires mi mai
chaque équipe par groupe de deux va
faire un mime et son contraire et
l'autre équipe devra dîner ce que c'est
ainsi que vous d'ailleurs on y va michel
et nathalie quand c
je vous cherchez bien alors il ya des
réponses garder la pizza la rapide et la
langue c'est sa rapide et lent arrête un
mime de l'autre équipe
hervé aimé y aller en place essayez de
trouver
oulala je range le chez eux nos amis
sont venus chercher
il a constamment trouvé est ici dans
l'île aux enfants a conduit toi jean qui
rit et jean qui pleure c'est ça on l'a
très bien
l'arrière de la moto les à vos places
j'ai cru qu'il respecte pas des clowns
vous en faites
le frère et la soeur là allez faites le
on va aller comme ça ça cherche attendez
attendez attendez un petit peu casimir
attendre casimir a peut-être répondre
d'abord casimir oui qu'est ce que c'est
celui qui courageux et courageuse et sa
courageuse stéphane et peureuse et
peureux christine ouais ça pas moi j'ai
triché parce que on va sauter les flics
il a soudé c'est mireille il a souhaité
qu'ils nous ont fait un maintenant alors
vous asseyez maintenant c'était très
bien
serge et jérôme hallé en place avant
l'aller contraire de serge et jérôme
alors oui mais lisse legros et le mens
tu crois que ça que j'aime et je croyais
que c'était françois et casimir ou et
c'était françois quasi néant
communication alors donc gros pénis ou
metz très bien qui nous en faire
maintenant
sandra ici le ministère vous cherchez
vous à leurs cendres accessible à tous
même s'il ya des réponses jérôme
carrasso est celui qui est bien éveillé
le paresseux et celui qui est bien
éveillé c'est ça on voit parfait asseyez
vous aie aie aie les deux frédéric là
n'est pas facile
qu'est ce que vous allez nous faire les
deux frédéric tiens allez le faire ici
loria frédéric et frédéric de justice
elle coiffera chez drouot à nos amis
kesher chez eux
j'ai signé russie est ambigu il trouve
pas grand chose le groupe pense que ce
mime jeu par frédéric et et frédéric
gros appétit iphone ou cd 106 frédéric
grands et petits
c'était très bien il est très bien écrit
de contraire qui donc est zémire quoi je
t'entends y canela mois et bien au
travail bon vieux à ton tour tu nous as
being sondés sont contrés rue et on l'a
on va voir ça il fallait aussi fort que
ça je sais pas si je vais aller voir à
temps à oui ça y est j'ai une idée
oui alors c'est ça tu peux recommencer
kazimi taxe a alors fait numéro un
voilà sa numéro deux c'est facile alors
vous pouvez pas gelli tu vois ce que
cette amérique mouche trouve pas
personne ne trouve mais nous de nous la
réponse
bon alors côté face
côté pile pile et face c'était facile